[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous il va qui
sont venus avec des images d'espèces
magnifique de paysages magnifiques
moi je suis venu avec un oeuf ce que
vous voyez au milieu et or cette hausse
va nous préoccuper dans le propos qui va
suivre
je travaille à muséum national
d'histoire naturelle donc c'est un
environnement un peu particulier
d'origine je suis épuisé mais titien
c'est à dire de l'épigénétique fin c'est
la science qui fait comprendre comment
l'environnement et donc notamment
l'alimentation influence l'expression de
nos jeunes
à côté de ça je trouve que je
m'intéresse aussi beaucoup à la
physico-chimie l'alimentation savoir
comment ce parce que les composés sont
transformés qu'est ce qui se passe quand
on cuisine qu'est ce qui se passe quand
on mange physiologie du goût
évidemment et à ce titre là donc je suis
responsable informations scientifiques
des prof de cuisine notamment donc le
propos qui va suivre est sûre la partie
cuisine pas sur la partie épigénétiques
je vous rassure tout de suite ça c'est
l'environnement un peu privilégié qu'on
a au muséum c'est grosso modo là la vue
de la fenêtre du labo alors vous pouvez
avoir l'impression que ce sont des
flamants roses mais pas du tout en fait
ce sont des flamands rouge
notre espèce et notamment des caraïbes
ça c'est facile de les distinguer ce que
les flamands roses en général sont roses
c'est ce que les flamands rouge comme
vous voyez en fait ils sont très très
rose et c'est comme ça qu'on peut qu'on
peut les distinguer alors c'est joli
comme image mais ce dont on se rend pas
compte sur la photo c'est que bath et
des bêtes qui patauge un peu on qui
laisse un peu traîné les bouts de
crustacés qu'on leur donne à manger donc
franchement des fois ça pue et ce qui
pose un problème et quand ça pue
vraiment trop en fait j'en arrive à
imaginer des solutions alors trouvé une
recette
le flamand donc ça c'est une recette
d'apicius appuyé sur ses instincts un
homme qui a vécu grosso modo de -30 à
+30 avant après jésus-christ donc sous
les empereurs notamment thibert et donc
on a il ya des écrits lors que
maintenant on sait que c'est pas de lui
mais bon on les associe à lui ou à sa
cour en tout cas donc cette magnifique
recettes dépouillait le flamand
lavez-les par l'homme était dans une
cocotte et de l'eau du sel de l'âne est
un peu de vinaigre à mi-cuisson lien
voter pour votre korian pour le faire
cuire la cuisson sera pas cet album
coloré mettez dans un mortier du poème
du commun
la demande de la russie n'est rien de
tout ça c'est de l'art cessait de la
recette ya juste le des frites home qui
peut vous poser une question en fait
c'est du moût de raisin donc si on
analyse un peu plus calmement la recette
on voit qu'en fait on prend une volaille
ont la plume ont une garniture
aromatique on l'a fait chauffer dans une
cocotte et puis à la fin on rectifie
l'assaisonnement et on lit la sauce fait
un coq au vin
c'est ce qu'on fait tout le temps donc
y'a rien de nouveau ce à cet égard de
milan donc aujourd'hui fondamentalement
la cuisine n'a pas évolué alors elle a
évolué en surface sur les
assaisonnements sûr il ya quelques idées
on va revenir sur quelques idées un peu
nouvelle qu'on peut avoir dans ses
fondamentaux la cuisine n'a pas évolué
qu'est ce que c'est que la cuisine on
trouve dans différentes définitions
c'est l'activité qui consiste à préparer
les repas ou plus prosaïquement l'art de
transformer les mets et si possible de
les rendre agréable où une bonne cuisine
qu'est ce que ça va être une bonne
cuisine va être une vénus va être bonne
pour les sens du goût tous acteurs
culturels bonne pour la santé c'est
aussi bonne pour le corps est maintenant
de plus en plus on a conscience du fait
aussi être bonne pour l'environnement ce
qui n'est pas forcément évident et du
coup évidemment pour atteindre cette
excellence dans cette cuisine qui doit
être bonne surtout tintin le tableau on
a besoin d'une connaissance et sa
brillat savarin avant d'être un fromage
à pâte grâce c'était un quelqu'un [ __ ]
juristes en l'occurrence jean l'antenne
moyens savarin dans son ouvrage le plus
célèbre la physiologie du goût il 125
nous dit la gastronomie c'est la
connaissance raisonnée de tout ce qui a
rapport à l'homme en tant qu'île sono et
dans cette connaissance
alain but cette connaissance à un but de
veiller à la conservation des hommes au
moyen de la meilleure nourriture
possible
donc c'est vraiment ça qui va nous
préoccuper comment atteindre cette
meilleure nourriture possible et brillat
savarin ailleurs dans son livre son
ouvrage continue de développent et 10%
avoir besoin de connaissances en
physique de connaissances en chimie de
connaissances en biologie de
connaissances en physiologie
c'est un peu ses connaissances qu'on va
prendre très rapidement
décortiquer ensemble pour ça je vais
faire quelque chose d'extrêmement
complexe je vais casser un oeuf un blanc
vous n'êtes là voilà of donc ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va fouetter un blanc
d'oeuf alors un blanc d'oeuf gouvernance
après très très évolué au niveau cuisine
ce que je vais vous faire mais donc
péter un blanc 2 ça consiste à côté de
l'eau un blanc d'oeuf et d'eau et des
protéines est évidemment si c'était
juste de l'eau je serais pas ce sera un
peu con mais là il ya il se passe
quelque chose d'autre que donc il ya des
protéines donc déjà sans être un grand
chimiste
on sait que s'ils se battent quelque
chose c'est grâce aux protéines qu'en
l'occurrence les protéines en bon la
canche en train de fouetter qu'est-ce
qui se passe body int et protéines
globulaires donc c'est des chaînes
d'acides aminés des acides aminés des
acides aminés europhobe hydrophile ont
normalement ils sont pelote mais en
fêtant les pilotes se débobine et
commettent les bobines de l'acide aminé
europhobe ils y sont pas contents d'un
point de vue énergétique parce que
normalement ils étaient cachés omis la
protéine vogler mais là ils sont exposés
à l'eau et comme ils sont exposés à
l'eau au 17e réfugiés mais qu'en même
temps je leur propose des bulles d'air
que je fais rentrer dans la route du
crime on se met autour des bulles d'air
et de kout mais muller / retrouve
recouverte de protéines et ça on n'y
pense pas toujours quand on tombe à les
blancs en neige
mais c'est quelque chose qui est
fondamental pour essayer de comprendre
qu'est ce qui est important quand on
fait un blanc ou pas il ya des
différences chose en cuisine sans
oublier les trucs qu'il faut surtout pas
faire battre
il faut surtout pas s'arrêter de
fouetter quand vous mettez un blanc
neige parce que sinon ça peut ça peut
poser problème
c'est un truc important mais sinon non
plus sérieusement pour vérifier que si
si ça ça marche
normalement quand on retourne le bol y
tient encore tout ça c'est ça c'est que
c'est réussi merci c'est juste un blanc
côté 1
et alors si vous retournez avec ça tombe
ça c'est le signe qu'il faut recommencer
donc ça ça marche bien ça marche bien
alors évidemment il ya plein de trucs et
astuces qu'on va trouver pour en vie par
un nombre des fois il faut mettre du sel
alors le salsa vous des ions
effectivement donné en disant sodium
effectivement lésions ces ions positifs
en a plus donc ça facilite le thé
bobinage et l'interaction des protéines
après pour entourer les bulles d'air un
jus de citron pareil c'est des protons
jus de citron ch plus donc ça va
faciliter le des bobinages interactions
des protéines sauf coach de citron le
problème c'est qu'ils aient un peu de
grave dans ce nom à jus de citron il ya
un peu de lipides
on a tendance à l'oublier c'est que des
fois ça a plutôt tendance à foirer donc
en fait je vous montrais un truc encore
plus un peu plus extrême et ça c'est
vraiment une petite astuce de cuisine et
je veux montrer ce que je peux en
vouloir pour montrer des petits trucs
oms à cette mousse je la jette et je
veux refaire une autre mais vous allez
voir c'est un peu la moue de l'extrême
un sac essayer de casser un blanc un
oeuf sur une table avec un amortisseur
c'était le challenge
voilà donc je mets mon blanc alors ce
que je vais faire c'est permettre de jus
de citron mais je vais mettre la
substance du jus de citron qui
normalement est censé remplir son rôle
c'est à dire vous avez de l'acide
citrique et citrix et casas qui fournit
l'acidité les protège plus dans le
citron et qui va permettre de d'apporter
son rôle faciliter l'interaction des
protéines donc un peu d'acide citrique
qu'est ce qu'on va mettre en permettre
du sel on va mettre du bicarbonate de
soude et de soude de non en fait c'est
bien là de sodium donc un a+ donc c'est
comme du cese dont il ya des ions jusque
là tout va bien et ce qui est marrant
c'est qu'on va bénéficier d'un troisième
effet si bien que quand on met ensemble
et ça je vous le montrer d'abord dans le
rire quand on est ensemble un acide
comme l'acide citrique donc faut être
costaud et parce que ce n'est pas le bon
côté quand on est ensemble un acide à
une base en milieu vous êtes des grands
chimistes en milieu aqueux ça nous donc
c'est génial
effectivement parce que du coup quand je
vais mettre mon acide citrique et mon
but car mode assaut de soude dans mont
blanc d'oeuf non seulement savent
acidifier apporter des proto h puces et
des lions sodium na plus donc ça va être
également plus ça à faire des bulles
d'air donc ça va faciliter la prise de
mousse non je mets un peu de bicarbonate
je mets un peu d'acide citrique voilà je
mélange gentiment et là je souhaite et
là je compte aller 1 2 3 4 5 et voir ses
prix alors je peux la serrer un peu et
ça permet de faire un blanc d'oeuf en 5
secondes au lieu au lieu d'une minute
pas enseignée à l'école hôtelière parce
que le truc c'est que ça allait vraiment
un goût dégueulasse mais ça mais dans
d'autres cas de figure il ya des trucs
qui marchent un tee shirt il n'y avait
pas deux c'était juste un exemple
alors il yad autres mousses parce que
l'art effectivement alors yedri qui
seront vraiment éviter vous allez dites
jus de citron attention il ya un peu de
gras dedans même chose pour le petit
coup de jaune d'oeuf qu'on laisse
traîner un savais que ça fait des
mousses qui sont un peu fragiles parce
que justement comme compris ce que je
vous ai expliqué comme c'est une
histoire de protéines qui veulent
interagir autour des bulles d'air qui en
fait joué un rôle de tensioactifs si je
redonne un peu de gras ils vont aussi
même protéine vont tenter d'émulsion et
le gras donc en fait bon être en
compétition et hors compétition entre
l'eire et le gras donc quand il ya du
gras qui traînent dans un blanc d'oeuf
ça fait des mousses
vraiment pas efficace des mousses
fragile et pour ça qu'il faut absolument
éviter la chose donc surtout pas traces
de jaune d'oeuf pas travailler qu un
saladier dans lesquels on a fait une
vinaigrette avance qui reste toujours un
peu de gras et c'est une catastrophe
bref ça c'est vrai il faut vraiment
faire attention à ça du coup du coup il
ya un truc qui est incompréhensible
c'est une autre sorte de mousse c'est la
chantilly quand je prends de la crème et
que je la fouettent que je fais là alors
là je vais miser dans un bol que j'ai
posées sur de l'eau avec un peu de glace
parce qu'il ya un truc qui peut faire
fois à la chantilly c'est quand on
travaille dans une pièce un peu chaude
mais donc lâché en confiance
et le fait est que quand on voit du coup
ça met de l'eau partout ce panache
d'odeur d un peu là dedans voilà quand
on souhaite donc là je suis sur la glace
que j'ai parties ont pas fait pour les
blancs d'oeuf
parce que là on sent bien que alors le
lait ça mousse un cappuccino ça marche
bien parce que la même raison dans les
cases in donc c'est les protéines auquel
on parle de tensioactifs donc le lait ça
mousse hills a fait naufrage il ya du
gras dans le dos donc là évidemment dans
la crème il ya tellement de gras vous
pouvez foot et de la crème comme vous
voulez température ambiante vous allez
faire du beurre pas de la chantilly
on sait bien que vont vers une chantilly
faut travailler très froid alors là
c'est ce que je fais je ferai en
travaillant très froid puisque j'ai posé
en vol sur de la viande fondante et donc
ce qui va se passer
rien à voir avec les tensioactifs dont
furtif qui n'ont pas grand rôle à part
qui va se passer
c'est en fait une mousse physique c'est
à dire que mc ren la cristalliser le
grade a cristallisé et en cristallisant
il devient de plus en plus rigides et en
devient de plus en plus rigide d'une
certaine manière ils empêchent les
leaders de sortir et donc j'ai une
mousse et cette fois ci un peu plus ce
qu'on pourrait considérer comme mousse
physique souvent de mousse chimique ces
interactions chimiques entre les
protéines qui chante les bulles d'air
1re cause de tensions actuelles et là
c'est une mousse qui tient du fait que
le matériel a cristallisé donc on est
beaucoup plus proche d'un phénomène
physique alors là quand un peu abusive
rappelé inventive fait aller pas à pas
très sucré parce que parce que j'ai pas
mis de sucre mais donc avec du sucre ça
s'appellerait une chantilly
mais c'est clair qu'avec un système
comme ça on peut on peut faire des
choses intéressantes
par exemple un peu près ce que j'aime
faire non plus plus sophistiqués et
évidemment ça c'est assez sympathique ce
type de textures mais l'idée c'est quand
même d'un peu d'un peu d'innover aussi
éventuellement des fois ci il faut aussi
être pas grand chose mais rien n'est si
l'âge et la chantilly puis la gema
mousse de blanc d'oeuf
bon ça la sela dégueulasse mais ses
parents c'est juste pour vous montrer et
si je mélange les deux en fait j'ai une
mousse une sorte de chantilly allégé
comme sushi thalassothérapie c'est
vraiment très bon alors on peut aussi la
détendre avec un sabayon peu sûr que la
chose voilà par exemple voilà son
chantilly salée alors c'est pas le
gentil mais c'est une crème fouettée
salée avec de l'huile d'olive l'huile
d'olive on peut la rajouter facilement
parce que c'est du gr20 dans le grâce à
ce but sonne très bien donc tout va bien
celle en l'occurrence défaite aussi font
un rossi vont se passer les bouteilles
sous pression on met le liquide qu'on
veut faire mousser on injecte une
cartouche de protoxyde d'azoté
c'est un additif 7950 sur les bons de
gentilles vous acheter dans le commerce
a marqué en 1950 puis du protoxyde
d'azoté
ceci c'est le gaz hilarant en fait c'est
que quand ce qu'on vous mais quand pour
vous regrettez une épaule quand j'ai
déboîté une épaule comme ça l'hôpital
ont un masque ses règles du protoxyde
d'azoté suspecte que ceci pour ça que
l'échantillon du succès là donc on
chantilly salle et c'est pas très
innovant c'est une crème fouettée à
l'huile d'olive tout va bien alors après
on a besoin de réfléchir un peu plus ça
c'est ce qu'on avait fait que le lycée
hôtelier de marseille en l'occurrence on
veut le faire une mousse d'huile d'olive
mais chaude alors là il ya une
catastrophe parce que si on fait une
moue de l'huile d'olive qu'on met des
artichauts barigoule dessous dans les
ici fin de sue l'artichaut vont faire
fondre matière grasse et du coup ça va
pisser de partout ça va être horrible et
puis on voulait envoyer sandra 80
couverts à servir soir là c'était pas
possible donc il a fallu trouver une
manière d'avoir une mousse qui tient là
faut réfléchir un peu à la physique il
faut se dire alors qu'est-ce qui peut
tenir dans l'histoire qu'est ce qui se
passe quand on cuit coagulation si
j'ajoute des protéines de blanc d'oeuf
dans ma mousse mais du coup s'il a fait
coaguler dans un siphon à 65° bain-marie
ça va marcher oui eh bien c'est
exactement ce qui se passe ici ça qu'on
a mis du blanc d'oeuf un ami dans un
siphon au bain marie pendant la grève
quand on sort la mousse qui sort de sa
fait une mousse chaude qui tient très
bien puisque en fait elle tient non pas
grâce à la cristallisation de matières
grasses maintien grâce au fait que les
protéines on coagulé donc ça fait un peu
comme un soufflé sur un souffle et un
soufflé je prends des blancs d'oeuf
et dans n'importe quoi des jaunes mais
jaune de grand marnier
je passe à auch où ça monte ça coagule
et ça tient c'est extrêmement robuste la
cuisine d'ailleurs une petite anecdote
c'est qu'on avait fait pour un tournage
pour m6 on m'a demandé de montrer qu est
ce qui est important dans un souffle est
donc toujours dans ces cas là on
commence par les souffles et y marche
bien donc quand j'avais bien travaillé
fait de souffle et iman cameraman
étaient super contents ils avaient du
temps tout ce qu'ils voulaient pour
filmer souffler sa retombée absolument
pas prêts a dit ben maintenant à faire
le soufflet qui ratent donc on a fait un
peu n'importe quoi on mélange de
n'importe comment on ouvert la porte du
four 4 x etc
et c'était un drame parce que j'ai
jamais réussi à rater quoi et on a en a
chaque fois en sortie le souffle et
caméraman était là alors ça retombe pas
alors comment celle du mathan là je veux
vraiment raté et en fait on n'a pas
réussi à rater notre région n'a triché
un peu pour la mission mais comme quoi
des fois c'est cette fois c'est
difficile par internet puisque à
d'autres comme nous d'ailleurs racing ce
chocolat dans un blanc d'oeuf comme ça
vous mettez du chocolat ou mettez au
frigo sauf une mousse au chocolat
si vous êtes végétaliens ou vegan comme
on dit vous avez compris que ce qui est
important c'est de souhaiter un truc
avec des protéines dedans et bien un jus
de pois chiches
c'est ce qu'ont fait qu'on appelle
l'aquaplanage du pois chiche a plein de
protéines on fouette le jus de pois
chiche on met du chocolat fondu on met
au frigo ça fait une mousse au chocolat
car un goût de pois chiche mais non
quand on veut on s'habitue à tout et ça
c'est une hausse de 1,6 à mousse de
chêne latine alors vous avez latine
c'est une protéine
donc je vais de la gélatine dans une
note il manque donc j'avais fait un
coulis de mangue un peu dessus gélatine
on fouette samus ça fait un peu fragile
dans nos classes est plutôt passé aussi
fond c'est plus costaud donc on met levé
dans le siphon tac on monte en pression
shut up et puis ça fait vraiment comme
texture non grasse assez juste un peu de
gélatine et coulis de mangue vraiment
comme une texture de mousse à raser mais
beaucoup plus simple en bouche et ça
fait d un truc qui est vraiment qui est
pratique pour faire des belles de belnus
alors évidemment quand on pense à la
science
tout de suite on dirait un truc de
cuisine moléculaire et c'est vrai qu'en
même temps qu'elle est apparue cette
volonté de comprendre ce qui se passe en
cuisine avec la science si à paris un
certain nombre de jeux autour de cuisine
un peu extrême
on l'a notamment ces filaments de
chocolat passé à l'azoté liquide donc
moins 200 degrés devant le client c'est
sympa ça fait du spectacle la vapeur par
tout ça croque à la maison sont bien
vite et ce qu'on peut perdre des doigts
mais
c'est sympa en restauration alors c'est
pareil ce qui a été à la mode c'est tout
les éditions alors carraghénanes
alginate donc à ses spaghettis de
fraises taxer un jus de fraise gélifiée
avec des carraghénanes et puis des
espèces de 9 mai deux structures à
solenzo ça fait pas du neuf mais là
c'est un épais de caviar et avec de
l'alginate alors ça bon c'est naturel
original carraghénanes s'extrait drague
mais aujourd'hui c'est carrément ringard
ce genre de truc revient on n'a pas
besoin de gélifiants à regarder ici
c'est juste des peptides naturel vous
faites une compote compote pomme cassisi
compote de pommes voulait talent et vous
mettez au four 60° fait sécher et vous
sortez ce qu'on appelle un cuir de
fruits et ça pas besoin de d'astuces un
additif ou quoi que ce soit ça marche
très bien et enfants adorent ça si vous
avez du chocolat vous détourner la
recette vous vous achetez de la pectine
de fruits qui vous la mettez dans du
chocolat fondu ou fait c'est si vous
avez un cuir de chocolat après vous
tailler un vêtement une veste de
chaussures de ce que vous voulez et ça
marche super bien c'est un peu gras au
contact de la peau mais ça marche bien
alors y'a pas que la physique et la
biologie
il y aura aussi sans contrainte par la
physique et la chimie et la biologie
là c'est la biologie qui a bossé dans ce
cas un chocolat ou 7 chocolatines sur
l'endroit d'où vous venez
il ya des alvéoles driver lol qui sont
la signature d'une activité levure yens
c'est quand est ce qu'on appelle une
pâte levée feuilleter ce qu'on a fait
comme du pain mais qu'on a fait faillite
et en plus il y avait de l'éleveur en
fait dans la fermentation fond des
alvéoles qui après se gonfle de vapeur
d'eau à la cuisson et ça fait c'est
magnifique schéma qui sont vraiment dû à
la biologie microbiologique a bossé dans
ce système ces merveilleux ça c'est
quelque chose qui devient de plus en
plus à la mode sont des grains de kéfir
en cuir lacée petits grains qui
ressemble à de la semoule en fait à
l'intérieur c'est des dizaines de
bactéries et de levure
pourtant les met dans de l'eau avec un
peu de sucre ça fermente ça fait des
boissons sainte a de plus en plus de
chefs qui commence à jouer avec ça parce
qu'ils ont compris qu'on pouvait
développer des goûts intéressant on peut
le servir dans des jurons peut faire
réduit on veut faire des tas de choses
donc ça c'est vraiment des pistes
d'innovation alors parlons d'innovation
il faut vraiment se débrider par rapport
à ça de nouveaux brillat savarin nous
encourage à innover à la découverte dame
est nouveau et plus pour le genre humain
et la découverte d'une étoile quand même
pas rien et j'ai rien contre les
astrophysiciens
mais c'est juste pour se motiver un peu
évidemment on va dire mais quelle est la
stratégie à adopter pour ça et edison
nous l'a donnée la stratégie pour une
bonne idée il suffit d'être plein
d'idées et en cuisine ça marche bien et
pour ça faut vraiment désacraliser la
cuisine c'est à dire que
dans ratatouille à rémy donc me dis que
tout le monde peut cuisiner et fera je
pense que c'est important d'aller plus
loin que sera et de se dire que ce qui
est important c'est pas seulement de
pouvoir mais c'est de le faire c'est
dans un monde où on se plaint tout le
temps que l'industrie agroalimentaire
nous empoisonnent que alignement ultra
transformés sont pas bons pour la santé
la meilleure manière de maîtriser
totalement son alimentation
et donc si possible son bien-être c'est
travailler les produits bruts et les
transformer soi-même
donc c'est pas seulement tout le monde
peut cuisiner c'est tout le monde doit
cuisiner
merci
[Applaudissements]